non que notre président de groupe là
aussi descendait de la tribune le Garde
des Sceaux a fait un bras d'honneur
c'est quelque chose d'assez à
qualifiable encore une fois nos
collègues ont été extrêmement surpris on
ne peut qu'être choqué par ce genre de
pratique encore une fois normalement un
ministre de la République au sein de
l'enceinte du Parlement devrait avoir un
devoir d'exemplarité manifestement il
n'en est rien alors est-ce que vous
l'aviez vu vous l'aviez vu le début
bien sûr très grave qu'on vient de
combien de traiter dont on vient de
parler mais c'est vrai que là on parlait
d'exemplarités beaucoup de gens parler
attendus des hommes et des femmes
politiques et ça en dit quand même très
long de l'effondrement de du niveau de
la de la vie politique on accuse souvent
les médias d'être à l'origine de
cet effort de rebord de la vie politique
ça se passe très bien jusque là jusque
là mais
je pense que c'est parfois les peut-être
que pourquoi c'est le comportement des
hommes et des femmes politiques qui peut
être plutôt des hommes d'ailleurs c'est
dérapage parfois des hommes qui est
aussi
on va en parler dans un instant qui fait
souvent des des voilà
c'est du buzz à l'Assemblée c'est vrai
que c'est l'endroit pour faire du buzz
seulement nous ici on n'aura pas de
faire du buzz mais nous on fait une
émission de télévision
on est dans les médias on n'est pas
l'assemblée c'est pas l'assemblée qu'on
va faire du buzz donc ils ont soit dit
de faire du buzz à l'Assemblée donc
après après ça donc après qu'il a
annoncé le geste gros bah gros bordel là
assembler sa gueule de partout alors y
a-t-il vraiment eu des bras d'honneur le
ministre répond et assume
j'ai été mise en examen je ne suis pas
condamné je conteste totalement
totalement l'effet qui me sont reprochés
maintenant il y a pas un bras en donneur
il y en a deux mais accompagné de parole
à chaque fois qui sont de quoi vous
parlez exactement vous avez fait deux
bras d'honneur c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de dire à l'Assemblée alors oui je
vous demande effectivement de préciser
vos propos parce que si c'est le cas ça
n'est absolument pas admissible j'ai dit
Madame bras d'honneur à la présomption
d'innocence je l'ai dit de voir
alors Olivier donc bon là c'est vrai que
c'est incroyable on a l'impression
d'être avec la CPE non mais c'est vrai
avec une classification
en retour des séances les choses les
choses ont continué le ministre c'est
d'abord pas excuser mais conseiller que
le geste n'était pas adéquat regarde
personne
ne peut dire ici dans cette hémicycle
que depuis un peu plus de deux ans et
demi que je suis ministre je n'ai pas
été respectueux du Parlement
j'ai entendu les propos du président
Marleix sur ma mise en examen je veux
rappeler que non seulement je suis
présumé innocent et constitutionnel
mais je suis innocent et je le dirai le
moment venu effectivement madame la
Présidente j'ai réagi avec beaucoup de
vivacité je concède madame la Présidente
que ce geste n'était pas un geste
adéquat voilà alors est-ce que est-ce
que il vous a parlé après ce que vous
êtes
non non il a eu à propos d'excuses après
mais j'ai pas échangé avec lui
personnellement vous avez pas vous
n'êtes pas parlé vous allez vous a pas
appelé derrière non non
je t'ai pas personnellement je m'en
fiche c'est vraiment le geste à l'égard
de la présentation dans l'hémicycle ça
aurait été c'est la première fois qu'un
membre du gouvernement se prête à un
geste de ce type il y a déjà des
dérapages entre députés alors j'observe
que les députés sont sanctionnés très
durement depuis quelques mois c'est
vérité d'ailleurs mais voilà que ça
arrive à ministre par n'importe lequel
le ministre de la justice il a pris une
circulaire d'ailleurs lui-même au moins
en septembre je crois 2020 pour demander
au procure ur d'être beaucoup plus
sévère à l'égard des des insultes des
injures contre les élus montre un
magnifique exemple
alors ce que je dis parce que je fais
tout le monde a réagi la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale regardez ce
qu'elle a dit
si l'effet qui dont on parlait était
avéré que c'était quelque chose de grave
qu'il fallait qu'il s'excuse qu'il
s'excuse auprès de l'institution auprès
des parlementaires dans leur ensemble de
la présidente de séance évidemment et si
ce geste était adressé un parlementaire
il fallait qu'il présente également ses
excuses auprès de ce parlementaire qu'il
faut que tout le monde
retrouve son calme il faut que nous
arrivions à avoir des débats qui soient
respectueux de chacun donc il faut être
respectueux ces interlocuteurs mais il
faut être évidemment respectueux avant
tout des Français
Olivier Véro aussi pourtant du
gouvernement qui réclamait de
l'exemplarité ministre des Sports aussi
qui Gabriel Attal il y en a qui ont
demandé sa démission on va voir regarder
ce qu'a dit Olivier Véran ce matin
évidemment on ne doit pas faire de bras
d'honneur dans l'hémicycle que le
ministre a très clairement expliqué et
il s'en est excusé que ces gestes ne
visaient pas un député en particulier
mais qu'il s'est accompagné il était
accompagné de parole qu'il a prononcé
qui ne s'entendaient pas dans le micro
mais qui ont été entendus par les
députés autour de lui ou juste un bras
d'honneur à la présomption d'innocence
suite à l'intervention d'un
parlementaire qui manifestement
ne laissait pas une frontière entre la
présomption d'innocence et la
culpabilité non c'est un peu une galère
si vous faites arrêter par des policiers
ou les gendarmes je vous déconseille le
bras d'honneur même en disant que c'est
abandonneur à la présomption de nos
chances est-ce que vous passerez la nuit
en garde à vue quoi pensez que vous
étiez vraiment destiné
oui et puis pas qu'un deux peut-être
même trois d'ailleurs
j'ai croisé son regard à la fin j'ai pas
de doute sur le fait que ça mettait ici
d'ailleurs alors on dit qu'il y en a eu
trois d'ailleurs il a changé oui je
crois qu'il y en a trois il a changé
d'ailleurs d'argumentation au début il
dit c'est un bras d'honneur à la
présence après il dit c'est parce que
j'étais sous le coup de ce coup de la
colère et de l'énervement
j'avais en tête en voyant ça peut figer
pas totalement surpris venant de
Monsieur Dupont-Moretti parce qu'il
était un habitué des de de de des actes
de des paroles un peu brutales des
comportements comme ça un peu grimaçant
quand on parle il y avait une grosse
embrouille en juin 2021 il était à
l'époque en campagne dans les hauts de
France pour les régionales ils sont
brouillé avec Damien Rieu qui est à
l'époque on rassemblement national
c'était sur une terrasse de la ville de
Péronne regardez
une de Monsieur
et Madame Le Pen elle a défendu en
algérien en situation irrégulière
elle
a la trouille
[Musique]
alors allez faire votre boulot vous avez
pas le temps d'être en vacances
je travaille dix fois plus que bien on
voit ça on voit ça
c'est je commence à le kiffer moi il a
il y a un truc alors il y avait
également haute séquence culte et
surtout plus rigolote c'est lorsqu'il
était avocat qu'il défendait à l'époque
Patrick Balkany Patrick m'avait coupé la
parole devant les caméras il avait pas
trop kiffé regardez
dans un état psychologique très fragile
c'est incontestable
son mari qui est à 71 ans qui l'a
découvertes inanimée qu'il a pensé mort
bientôt ma vieille
70 ça me suffit avec
[Musique]
Eric Zemmour sur Paris Première regardez
si ce n'était tous en grève mais rien un
peu comment on aurait du mal à circuler
en taxi à ramasser nos poubelles
soufflet mais vous êtes vous êtes comme
tapis vous êtes un ringard du pont
Moretti vous êtes pas là pour dire que
ce que je raconte c'est bidons si non
parce que si les Arabes demain et les
immigrés et tous les gens qui sont venus
ici se barrent vous êtes dans la merde
pour faire votre ménage vous avez
compris ça c'est argument de bidon bobo
de bourgeois qui vous vous êtes un
client
non attends
et voilà c'est vrai que voilà on a
d'autres clashs avec Eric Dupond-Moretti
on a qui demande sa démission qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez vous franchement
c'est la responsabilité du Président de
la République moi j'aime pas demander la
démission des gens mais c'est la
responsabilité ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est quand même je pense à tous
ces enseignants qui sont confrontés à
des élèves pas toujours très respectueux
quel exemple quel exemple on donne quoi
je pense à tous les tous les agents des
services publics qui se font un peu
malmenés à l'accueil qui qui suit des
propos brutaux voilà ils donnent le
sentiment que que tu souhaites autorisé
parce que c'est le gouvernement montre
l'exemple quoi donc c'est c'est pas
tolérable dans ces fonctions alors il
avait également été envoyé avec
Christine Angot On n'est pas couché sur
France de regarder
exposé publiquement un passé sentimental
dont peut-être madame n'a pas envie de
parler vous êtes allé très loin on n'est
pas au tribunal ici pardon je trouve ça
d'une violence madame incroyable je vais
vous dire une chose vous allez très bien
agressif
par exemple de madame
[Applaudissements]
si vous êtes très agressif si vous
voulez un jour vous êtes très agressif
non mais madame pas du tout je trouve un
peu choquant vous avez le droit de
s’était que son livre vous avez le droit
de ne pas l'aimer moi je connais pas
Madame quand on fait ce que vous faites
il faut que vous acceptiez le principe
c'est une contradiction
journaliste vous n'avez pas
m'interrompre une journaliste alors vous
avez pas invité alors mais je vous ai
pas invité moi je choisis pas les
invités
juste parce que il a aussi clasher le RN
à l'Assemblée il y avait poussé un coup
de gueule contre la récupération
politique de l'affaire Lola à
l'Assemblée regardez juste titre je vais
vous dire les choses comme je l'ai
ressent faire de la petite politique de
la petite polloche
se servir du cercueil d'une
guêpe 12 ans comme on se sert d'un
marche-pied c'est une honte monsieur le
député
ne rajoutez pas à l'atrocité la plus
absolue le commerce indigne de la
démagogie car vous êtes toujours au
rendez-vous du malheur dont vous faites
depuis des années votre miel c'est un
député de mon groupe qui
répondait j'avais trouvé sa formule
horrible ça formule a été calculée se
servir du du cercueil d'une gamine de 12
ans etc comme la marche pied c'est une
formule qu'il avait choisi qu'il avait
travaillé je devais trouver ça aussi
choquant que la maladresse de dont le
propos qu'il dénonçait
un professionnel de de l'art oratoire
d'expression orale et il en joue il en
abuse hier c'est bras d'honneur par
exemple ils étaient faits très
discrètement sous faut pas être trop vu
un peu sous le sous la table il fait
quand vous lui dites des choses qui lui
plaît pas comme ministre il vous fait
des grimaces en espérant ne pas être
filmé c'est voilà quelqu'un qui est pas
très correct sa façon de de faire est-ce
qu'il peut y avoir des sanctions il y a
que le Président de la République qui va
qui peut décider où est-ce qu'il peut
être ne pas venir à l'Assemblée
mis au point non ça se fait pas en fait
ils sont sanctionnés
nationale les députés sont sanctionnés
de la France insoumise sur honnête il se
serait pris à la demande de la majorité
de mode suspension d'interdiction de son
mandat alors qu'ils sont quand même un
élu du peuple dans tous les cas pour les
hommes on les aime pas mais on est
titulaire d'un mandat aujourd'hui le
président de l'Assemblée elle n'a pas de
pouvoir de des habitudes
elle a pas de pouvoir sur des membres du
gouvernement en tout cas elle a écrit à
la première ministre on lui rappelant
que c'était son devoir à elle de faire
peu respecter voilà des règles
essentielles de de de politesse de de
bien de comportement républicains voilà
donc c'est la responsabilité de
ça vous a choqué ce geste où vous en
foutez vous avez fait juste un beau si
vous êtes différent
pour moi titre personnel je mange je
m'en fiche mais en tant que député je me
dis qu'il y a des fondrement il faut
encore de de du niveau du débat
politique
n'exagon pas c'est pas moi
forcément pour vous c'est toujours bon
non écoutez je sais pas non plus très
agréable de comme comme il y a des
choses plus intéressantes à faire je
pense dans la vie politique mais il y a
un moment faut aussi dire stop sur
certains comportements quoi une fois
encore voilà les vous pensez que tous
les gens qui ont à faire face à ce
problème de de lire respect qui ont à
faire respecter l'autorité lui son
boulot c'est c'est d'abord ça c'est
faire respecter l'autorité de la loi
quoi il prend des circulaires pour dire
il faut sanctionner les gens qui sont
irrespectueux à l'égard des détenteurs
d'autorité publique et il fait des bras
d'honneur dans l'Assemblée nationale
c'est juste pas possible il y a juste un
moment où il faut siffler la fin de la
récréation le seul qui peut le
sanctionner donc c'est le président de
la présidente Emmanuel Macron est-ce
qu'il trouve ça normal est-ce que pour
lui c'est un exemple il a dû il a dû
l'appeler aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron
c'est sûr il l'a appelé il a dû lui dire
oui c'est pas exprimé de prendre la
République et Elisabeth borne s'est
expliqué première ministre regardez ce
qu'elle a dit
de toute façon monsieur Dupont-Moretti
aurait dû démissionner le jour où il a
été mise en examen donc là il fait des
bras d'honneur je veux dire mais perdre
tous leurs nerf là ces gens-là ils sont
usés ils ne je crois qu'ils n'ont pas
l'intérêt de la France ils n'ont pas le
goût de la France le garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice se comporte comme
j'allais dire dans une cour de récré ou
une guérilla de d'automobiliste au bord
du périphérique c'est un digne voilà en
faisant un bras d'honneur à la
représentation nationale en fait c'est
aux Français qui fait un bras d'honneur
en fait derrière ce geste
grossier hors-durier vulgaire
inadmissible quand on est ministre ça
traduit vraiment la manière dont le
gouvernement considère le peuple
français
automobilistes c'est vrai que c'est
malheureusement on a tous été victime tu
sais ce genre de choses et on est choqué
que le ministre de la justice fasse ça
au bord du gouvernement de République
française c'est quand même c'est quand
même un peu trop quoi alors on va mettre
ce qu'a dit Elisabeth borne Premier
ministre c'est ce qu'elle a dit mettez
le tweet s'il vous plaît merci merci ils
ont pas ils ont pas le plus important
comme d'habitude non mais l'exploitation
ou l'instrumentalisation politique ça
c'est du grand classique mais en
revanche moi je pense que moi titre
personnel tout le monde s'en fout mais
je trouve que c'est un scandale ses bras
d'honneur mais en revanche je pense que
c'est surtout un cadeau empoisonné pour
le gouvernement et ça m'étonne que
Macron ne réagisse pas parce que il
voudra ils vous font la danse là pour la
réforme des retraites ils ont besoin de
vous des LR au Sénat donc malgré tout
vous pensez pas qu'ils sont très très
embêtés au gouvernement et qui vont
peut-être agir je j'espère que ça des
chocs j'espère que ça mènera une action
c'est que dans une semaine ça sera
oublié et que le président va passer à
autre chose il va pas désavouer
Eric Dupond-Moretti pour deux bras
d'honneur ou trois bras d'honneur à
l'Assemblée en ça je peux vous le dire
je je je vous donne n'importe quoi s'il
arrive il y a déjà un certain niveau de
cynisme puisque le président de la
République actuelle
c'est assis sur une règle que c'est
prédécesseurs ont toujours respecté
depuis juin 1993 qui consistait à
demander à un ministre mis en examen de
quitter le gouvernement là il est
ministre de la justice il est mis en
examen pour des fêtes dont on peut juger
pas gravité extrême peut-être enfin
c'est quand même de la prise dégâts
d'intérêt c'est vrai qu'il est interfilé
accusé d'avoir interférer dans un
dossier de concernant le président
demander une enquête pour trouver les
gens qui avaient pu balancer des infos
et il est mis en examen mais il reste
ministre de l'innocence
il est quand même mis en examen ça a été
décidé par une cour de justice alors il
nous a mis aussi un petit accla nous
hein petite cartouche quand on avait
demandé des procès rapide
lorsqu'on avait été extrêmement choqué
par le meurtre de la petite Lola
regardez
2 millions de téléspectateurs je
m'échine à mieux faire connaître la
justice à montrer combien la justice
c'est difficile de la rendre et on
balaye ça d'un revers de manche il dit
Monsieur Hanouna ça c'est l'époque dans
laquelle nous vivons il faut s'adapter à
l'époque mais si c'est ça l'époque dans
laquelle on vit on est tombé franchement
bien bas c'est la négation de l'État de
droit l'État de droit il nous protège il
protège monsieur Hanouna aussi et le
balayer comme ça pour au fond flatter
les bases instincts faire de l'audience
de de l'audimat moi c'est quelque chose
qu'à titre personnel je ne peux pas
accepter bon maintenant on se rend
compte qu'il y avait vraiment dit
n'importe quoi quelques temps après non
mais c'est vrai voilà on se rend compte
une fois de plus voilà on voit que il a
voulu faire aussi une sortie une saillie
contre nous pour faire parler de lui en
tout cas moi ce que je vois c'est que
les les parents de la petite Lola on
pense surtout à eux et je pense qu'il
aurait mieux fait de parler des parents
de la petite là plutôt que de vraiment
de de je vous dis du choc qu'on a eu
tous et de l'émotion qu'on a eu après ce
ce crime qui nous a tous retourné et on
sait tous mis à la place je vous dis de
de des parents de la petite Lola et on
sait tous imaginer parents de la petite
Lola et forcément on a parlé avec
émotion alors la justice bien sûr fait
son travail la justice est très bien
mais l'émotion un moment c'est important
et je pense que il devrait avoir un
petit peu plus d'émotions aussi Éric
Dupond-Moretti notre garde des sceaux et
que à un moment il faut parler non pas
avec les lois mais avec le cœur voilà et
je pense voilà quand on est lui il a pas
eu le moche moi je peux comprendre qu'il
est aussi une émotion hier et qu'il ait
fait trois bras d'honneur parce qu'il
est fatigué il est excédé on va pas lui
jeter la pierre mais on va pas tirer sur
l'ambulance je vous dis la vérité voilà
il est peut-être fatigué il sait qu'il
s'en prend des cartouches de partout
voilà un moment bah il a craqué voilà
donc lui aussi il a eu hier ce qu'on
appelle une émotion nous on a parlé avec
émotion d'un meurtre atroce et on s'est
dit on veut que les coupables et la
coupable ou la présumé coupable soit
puni et soit jugé rapidement vite je
pense que c'est moins grave que de faire
des des bras d'honneur à l'Assemblée
voilà après chacun placera ce qui est
grave ce qui est moins grave selon une
échelle de Richter de la gravité
Olivier avec ce que vous avez un dernier
mot à dire
je trouve que les hommes politiques ont
quand même un devoir d'exemplarités si
on veut que les Français respectent un
peu plus sa politique ça se tiennent un
peu moins se remettre à croire à la
politique
faut que les autres politiques montrent
l'exemple et arrête de faire du théâtre
se comporte bien cherche un peu moins
les effets de manche cherche un peu
moins à faire le buzz à faire le
spectacle et faire leur boulot c'est
devenu un bordel pas possible un peu
plus de danser
que s'il était un jour ministre ce
serait le bordel vous avez pu repasser
l'extrait aussi ce serait le bordel on y
arrive il faut pas dire c'est pas Éric
Dupont bruits de Gilles Verdun
les amis de Gilles Verdez il a pas eu de
problème avec lui à assembler voilà
c'est la première fois oui mais c'est
surtout les potes de Gilles Verdez les
amis Gilles Verdez merci